mes chers compatriotes on dit souvent
qu'il est moins difficile de faire son
devoir que de le connaître voilà
pourquoi depuis 10 8 mois et dans ces
derniers 15 jours j'ai tout fait pour
vous informer et pour vous présenter un
programme le général de Gaulle dit
souvent que l'opposition est divisée il
n'y paraît pas en ce qui concerne le
programme puisque le mien a été repris
par tous les autres candidats seul
toutefois j'ai apporté les moyens pour
le réaliser
je les rappelle d'un mot baisse des
impôts compensé par des économies sur
l'aide au monde entier et sur la force
de frappe augmentation de la production
augmentation général des salaires
fixation des pris agricoles au niveau
européen cela personne ne vous l'a dit
et je pense que vous vous en souviendrez
à aprèsdemain aujourd'hui dans ce
dernier appel j'appelle votre attention
sur le fait que la France pendant 2 mois
aura besoin d'être gouvernée en
attendant l'élection d'une nouvelle
Assemblée national j'ai pensé qu'il
était conforme à l'esprit de la
Constitution que ce soit le président
bonerville qui occupe pendant ce temps
le poste de Premier ministre son courage
et son attachement à la République sont
connus c'est lui que je
solliciterai afin de présider le
gouvernement jusqu'à ce que la majorité
issue des élections puisse
décider en second lieu un très grave
danger nous menace le général de Gaul a
dit qu'il ne terminerait pas son mandat
je vous préviens que dans les 2 mois de
sa réélection
éventuel il fera un nouveau référendum
et il vous demandera tout simplement
l'autorisation de désigner lui-même
l'homme qui sera appelé à finir ce
mandat le peuple ne se déjugera pas à 2
mois d'intervalle et ainsi dans moi mes
chers compatriotes la République risque
d'être présidée par un homme que vous
n'aurez pas élu en votant pour de Gaulle
vous voterez pour un autre homme que
vous ne connaissez pas devant un tel
péril je suis convaincu que la majorité
des Français souhaite que le général de
Gaulle arrête là ses fonctions
présidentielles
mais il existe des majorités qui peuvent
se transformer en minorité si les moyens
employer pour la réunir ne sont pas
rassemblés je viens vous dire ce soir si
monsieur mitran arrive second dans une
élection où seul les deux premiers
peuvent participer au second tour si
monsieur mitran arrive second comme il
bénéficie du soutien à ces indiscret du
Parti communiste nombre d'électeurs se
détourneront de lui et le général de
Gaulle sera
réélu ceux qui votent pour Monsieur le
Canouet doivent savoir que pour leur
part il m'empêche de parvenir à la
seconde place qui peut assurer un deè
tour victorieux c'est bien pourquoi
c'est une immense union des masses
populaires de notre pays qui doit se
réaliser autour de ma candidature cette
union mes chers compatriotes
elle est heureusement maintenant
possible le président du Conseil
National de la Résistance pendant la
guerre le Président George Bidau vient
d'adresser un appel en ma faveur je
salue voyez-vous cet appel comme la
réconciliation définitive de tous les
Français de bonne foi je le salue parce
qu'il permet à tous ceux qui ont
conservé la foi dans la grandeur
véritable de notre patrie de se
reconnaître de s'unir et de s'aimer mais
il n'est pas de foi sans espérance je
vous apporte l'espoir de 7 ans de
stabilité dans
l'expansion et non dans la régression
reste bien entendu l'homme l'homme que
je suis en vérité nous commençons à
mieux nous connaître mes chers
compatriotes et vous avez pu en
m'entendant en me regardant vérifier la
fausseté des vieilles attaques portées
contre moi cela n'a rien d'étonnant car
je viens d'une province le béarne d'où
un homme est déjà parti
jadis pour devenir le chef de la France
c'était Henri
et il a su réconcilier et
rassembler une France alors cruellement
divisée il se souvenait ement de ces
temps anciens où à la petite cour de
Navar il n'y avait plus d'héritier malâ
et le bon Gaston phbus alla par de les
monts d'Espagne à la cour d'Aragon pour
demander un prince susceptible de régner
on lui en présenta deux c'était deux
jumeau il venaent de Na fbus se pencha
sur les berceaux il vit que l'un avait
les points fermés et que l'autre avait
les mains ouvertes il emporta celui qui
avait les mains ouvertes en signe de
réconciliation et de paix ce sont mes
chers compatriotes ces mains que je vous
tends
prenez-les après-demain dimanche et
ensemble
nous parcourrons la route qui mène dans
le chemin de l'avenir et vers le
bonheur vive la
France Libre forte et
fraternel vive la
république